how do you keep your space clean so that
you can keep being artistic and keep
seeing the truth within yourself and
others and not getting right there's so
much noise out there in the world
there's noise with the news there's
noise with you know drama I mean it's
drama go into the grocery store right
now it's masks on like there's just so
much noise that goes on that for me it's
I mean I have to make a conscious effort
to you know keep the energetic space
clean do you feel like you have to do
that and if you do like what are those
things how can we how can we learn from
you to be able to tap into our truth
which might be love it might be work it
might be a journey you know all of those
journey at work while you're in love
depending on who you worked for there's
lots of people in Silicon Valley micro
dozing at work yeah so I haven't had
cable or watch television in 20 years so
I don't watch the news I don't ingest
the news I don't have a single news
channel anywhere on my phone computer
anywhere a lot of people say oh you're
naive you're not in touch that's
actually not true people tell me what I
need to know trust me there's enough
information out there what I realize is
I'm very sensitive and I'm very easily
influenced so I realized that whenever I
would watch the news like I just felt
horrible and I was like why am i
watching why am I putting this you know
it's called programming for a reason
television is called programming so I'm
like why am i working so hard
programming my mind and a positive
mindset but putting in negative
information so for me it was a conflict
so I haven't watched a violent movie or
a scary movie and decades I just don't
do that I just so I keep it clean that
way also trying to live Integra
as much as I can you know watching
watching myself and how I operate
cleaning up really quickly of anything
that I feel bad or guilty for shouldn't
have said taking extreme accountability
and responsibility making my amends um
just it I try to keep my being as
energetically clean it clear as I can
you know it's if I feel guilty about it
or if it keeps trolling in my mind I'll
have to out myself like you know I told
you that and because I didn't want you
to believe this so I will actually have
those conversations
oh dude I've had conversations where I'm
about to puke in a trash can
yeah my mentor gate ought me that when
you're sick you should do a count within
yourself and see where you've been out
of integrity in your life check in and
see what pops up and like there's some
stuff that can pop up girl and yeah I've
literally had some conversations where
we can get into that at another point
but some pretty gnarly conversations and
amends that I needed to make things I
did that I didn't realize I feel guilty
for they actually still resided in my
consciousness so if you look at your
consciousness or your vibration or your
energetic state just did you do your
physical body you keep it as clean as
you can right you know
I that's what I do try to keep all that
clear and I really do surround myself in
beautiful environments I try to make
sure I'm in aesthetically pleasing
places for me you know I reduce
negativity I don't have anyone around me
that's negative I just don't I'm not the
person you call it a gripe I'm the
person you know even my children when
they call they know that I'm gonna say
you know they're like I have an earache
and I'll say well that's interesting
what are you not listening to so you go
into the energetic body oh yeah yeah
because I believe that too with even you
know the things that are unhealed I was
just having this conversation actually
with dad the other day as the talking
about things that I'm healing and I said
I literally think of something that
me up inside or something I haven't
gotten out I literally picture it like
cancer that's it don't get it out if I
don't say it if I don't cry if I don't
write it down if I don't where else
I literally just picture it like it's
gonna kill me and it does
that's literally what that is you know
Freud said secrets make you sick hmm
that was Sigmund Freud
[Music]
you
[Music]